A potential major development in Ukraine.
The United Kingdom has confirmed
that it is supplying
Ukraine with multiple storm
shadow cruise missiles.
This equipment
gives Ukrainian
forces a new, longer range
strike capability
in advance
of an expected counteroffensive
against Russian forces.
The news comes as Ukraine's
military says that its
troops have conducted what they call
effective counterattacks
in the buff moot area.
That city in the east
has seen fierce
fighting for 11 months now.
According to Kiev, Russian
troops have already been
pushed back
as much as two kilometers in some areas.
CNN's Nick Paton Walsh is in the Zappa
rich region.
Nick, Ukraine
has been asking
for missiles
with a longer range for some time.
It seems that they are
finally getting it.
What kind of a difference could this make
It does appear they already have them.
They've been asking the US to supply.
The attack comes with its 185 mile range.
But these UK storm shadows
have 155 mile range,
which essentially brings
much of the Crimean peninsula
occupied by Russia,
possibly even some part of Russia's
border areas,
although it's clear
as part of this donation
they will not be striking
inside Russian territory proper
before the 2014 reestablishing of borders
by Russia's occupation.
It does potentially
allow Ukraine to be more targeting
of key
Russian military infrastructure
in those occupied areas.
And I wonder
if this announcement
is perhaps coming out to be clear
that it's a UK donation
allowing them to have this greater
effective range.
So there's no confusion
as to
whether the US had, for example,
secretly supplied some extra capability.
It does potentially change the precision
and depth
that Ukraine can exercise
into occupied areas,
but also to it's important to point out
we've seen sabotage, we've seen drones
attacking some of these areas.
It seems over the past weeks too.
So a clear
sign,
I think, of the United Kingdom often
wanting to be the first to supply tanks
or seem the most pioneering
in terms of what
it's willing to give Ukraine.
Does that put greater pressure
on the United States
to add to the inventory?
We'll have to wait and see,
but it again
puts emphasis on
when this counteroffensive may begin
and we may see it
publicly We're hearing
today, too, from Russia's
mercenary head, Yevgeny Prigozhin,
that his forces are losing ground
in parts of Bermuda,
having to withdraw into that city center.
He says because of
Ukrainian counter offensive,
he goes on after days, frankly,
of railing
against the mismanagement of war
by the Kremlin's top brass.
He goes on to warn
this potentially could lead Ukraine
to push all the way
through and make a decisive strike
inside occupied areas.
On top of that to
ahead of this counteroffensive,
President
former President
Donald Trump's comments yesterday
refusing to say he wants Ukraine to win
the war.
That's going to focus a lot of minds here
as to how vital
this summer is
and how Western support
is a guarantee forever. Back to you.
No question about that, Nick Paton Walsh.
Something is happening in Baku.
We are getting more
and more reports from that region.
The next few days could be crucial.
Thank you so much for your reporting.
We're getting details of explosive
allegations this hour
from the US ambassador to South Africa
who accuses the government
of supplying arms to Russia.
Ambassador Reuben Brigety
told local news media
that arms and ammunition were loaded onto
a sanctioned Russian
cargo vessel late last year.
CNN's
David McKenzie joins us
live now from Johannesburg.
So, you know, we've seen South
Africa participating, David, in joint
military exercises with Russia.
Obviously,
they have refused to condemn the war,
at least against the Russians.
And they've also wavered about
how to potentially handle Putin,
maybe visiting South Africa
during the BRICS summit later on
this year.
That has caused the Americans
so much unease,
this idea that South Africa could indeed
be sending ammunition to Russia
clearly is a huge problem for the West
Well, it's a
huge problem
for the West,
but it's also a huge problem
for South Africa, Zain.
If it turns out to be true,
this is a sanctioned vessel
by the US last
May, as the vessel is a Russian cargo
ship known to be,
according to the US Treasury,
transporting weapons and ammunition
for the Russian Federation
over some time.
It was sanctioned last year.
And then you have
this mysterious situation
when the lady are, as it's known,
a doctor
in the main naval port of South Africa
in a military naval port
near Cape Town for several days.
And there were questions at that time,
what exactly was it doing,
the allegations from the opposition
that there were late night
cargo being taken on and off and all this
very direct statement
from the US ambassador to local media,
both on camera and in audio, saying that
they believe that this vessel left
South African shores
with Russian arms and ammunition.
When the ambassador was asked
how confident he is
on that intelligence,
he said, quote,
We are confident that the weapons
were loaded onto the vessel
and I would bet my life on it
is a very direct comments
from the most senior
diplomats
of the US here
in South Africa
and continues
these allegations against South Africa
that is not neutral,
but rather siding with Russia and
And David, it is very unusual,
as you just touched on there,
for an ambassador
to make an accusation like it
like this, isn't it
Yes, it is.
And I
think this would be
a very calculated move.
It's also
telling that the international media,
like CNN and others,
we're not invited to that briefing.
This is a message
meant for South Africa,
for the South African press,
of course,
due to the potential gravity
of these accusations.
It would become global news.
But this was a message
directed at South Africa,
at the president by the US ambassador.
You have seen a more assertive line
coming from US diplomats
about South Africa's
stance
on the Russian invasion
of Ukraine in recent months.
But this is certainly the most
direct accusation in that South Africa
is potentially arming
this state that invaded Ukraine.
We expect a statement
shortly from the South African presidency
on this matter.
I'm sure that will be forceful.
But they have repeatedly said here
in the country that they
are neutral on this issue,
though they
did host war
games with the Chinese
and the Russians earlier
this year and could be even hosting
Vladimir Putin later,
later this year at the BRICS summit.
So I'm sure they'll
be significant fallout
after these comments
from the US ambassador.
And if it more evidence does emerge
that weapons will be sent
from South Africa,
to Russia,
then it becomes also an issue
of sanctions busting.
Potentially,
though, South Africa maintains
it wants to maintain good relations
with all sides Zain.
Yeah, that may be difficult to do.
David McKenzie live for us there.
Thank you so much.